(logo whooshing)
(keys clicking brightly
- [Narrator] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(bright music)
- Welcome to A Conversation With History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Philip Pettit
who is the LS Rockefeller
University Professor of Politics
and Human Values at Princeton
and distinguished Professor of Philosophy
at the Australian National University.
He works in moral and political theory
and on issues in philosophy
of the mind and metaphysics.
His most recent book is,
Just Freedom: A Moral
Compass for a Complex World.
He is giving the Tanner
Lectures on Human Values
at Berkeley in 2015.
Professor Pettit, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- [Harry] Where were you born and raised?
- A small town of the
west of Ireland, Ballygar,
it's County Galway directly
across from Dublin.
- And looking back,
how do you see your parents
shaping your perspective
on the world?
- I was raised in quite
a religious family,
not sectarian I must say, Catholic,
but very, very encompassing,
very ecumenical in attitude
and I think it was through
probably religious themes
that I came to philosophy, an
interest in the big questions
which were obviously always put before you
about free will, about good and evil,
about the existence of
God, about an afterlife.
And these issues clearly for anyone
at that background are going
to be very, very prominent.
I went through standard schooling
where actually my interest
were mainly mathematics
and classics and went
to university intending
to do one or the other.
And in university
discovered the possibility
of doing philosophy which I
must say really excited me.
I thought the idea of being
able to spend time thinking
about these big questions
on which I had, after all,
just received religious instruction
so to speak for thinking for myself.
I found that really heady almost.
I remember the excitement
when I was 18 you know
that I could transfer to the subject.
So I did.
- And was the the leap
from viewing this as religious topics
to really viewing them in a secular way,
was that difficult for you?
Or it just flowed naturally?
- I think it really, in my own case,
it occurred mainly because
of reading Satre's.
I became very enthusiastic about his work.
I didn't for a moment believe it.
I mean coming in my background, after all,
here was someone, you
know, there was no God,
there was certainly freewill,
that it was a very extraordinary sort,
very different from the sort, for example,
that Aquinas would have articulated
that I would have learned.
But it was so exciting reading Sartre
'cause here was somebody who
dealt with the big questions,
who had different views from me
that I've been raised in
on almost every question,
who developed them this
wonderfully systematic way
and who also gave literary
expression to them
in both his plays
which I think are still
extraordinarily good
and his novels which are
maybe not so good as novels.
But they still give it
vividness to these themes.
For me that was probably
the most exciting intellectual
event in university
that I discovered Sartre
and I actually wrote an
undergraduate senior thesis
on Sartre.
I was completely converted
to philosophy from then on.
- In either before university
or during university,
were you engaged in politics at all?
- No, not immediate,
not as an undergraduate.
But I am, I'd rather unusual background.
At the same time when
I went to university,
I was also in seminary,
training with the idea of
becoming a Catholic priest.
So reading Sartre, for example,
I had to actually get the
permission of my bishop
to read Sartre because Sartre was
on the index of forbidden books
within the Catholic Church.
But I left the priesthood,
I mean I left that strand
and about three years in.
I then did a master's
degree which was rather
different from the Sartre work
and on basically the early
Bertrand Russell and G. Moore
and their thought.
I then, amazingly, this was 1968,
there were jobs aplenty
especially in Ireland and England
because all these new
universities had been created.
And so I think my MA examiners,
both my external examiner's
offered me a post
so I was teaching at 20, 21
I think I started teaching.
So I was junior faculty
when they the big revolts
happened in university,
in Berkeley of course but also in Europe,
including in Ireland.
So I was teaching at
University College in Dublin
in 1969, March '69 when
the student unrest began
and I did actually get
quite involved in that
as a sort of junior
faculty and in the end,
I mean I was one of the faculty
who was you know pro students
as you'd expect at that age and time
and I suppose given my own inclinations.
But the first book I actually published,
I think it's the only book
that's ever been in a
bestseller list actually,
was a collection of pieces
by quote, people described as
radical faculty and students
which I edited in 1969 in Ireland.
It was published under the title,
somewhat embarrassing now
as, The Gentle Revolution.
But it was sort of an Irish version
of Paris (speaking in foreign language)
and of what was happening
in Berkeley at the time.
Probably a more modulated moderate version
than what was happening elsewhere.
- We're gonna talk about
your book on freedom shortly
but I'm curious to what
extent did the experience
in the Catholic Church on the one hand
and the student activism on the other,
did they point you in the direction
of this focus on freedom.
- I think probably the exposure
to Sartre very early on put the theme
of freedom very, very
prominently in my mind.
I mean Sartre was focused of course
and I've always been in
interested in that too,
on what we would call free will
or on the freedom of an agent
to go with his or her judgment
rather than desires and so on.
But problem for him
and it comes out in his
work as it develops,
is how to translate that into
a political ideal of freedom
and that always concerned me.
So that team was there very
early on that was some,
I mean it was probably
15 or 20 years later
before I began writing very explicitly
about the political ideal of freedom.
- I like to ask my guests about
the skills and temperaments
that they think are prerequisites
or helpful in the career
that they've chosen.
So what do you see as important
skills for a philosopher?
- Obsession.
I think the capacity to
become completely obsessed
with the problem or with an idea
so that you don't just read about it,
you don't just write about it
but you think about it.
It's the first thing
that comes to mind when
you have a spare moment,
in the doctor surgery or
on the bed in the morning
or whatever it might be.
Just to be able to return to the thought
or the idea or the problem
and think it quietly through
and keep your mind focused on it.
See I think that's it's really
a sort of obsession I think.
I'd have to say that it's
like riding the tiger
in Mao's phrase, you
know, I think you've got
to have that obsession
and and live with it too.
At least that's what I found
that works in my own case
in dealing with a problem.
It's always that obsession
that's pushed me towards
publishing something,
writing something that I may,
of course be more or less happy with
but that's certainly I
think a driving force.
- And it must also be the ability
to transcend frustration
'cause it must be very frustrating
when you're alone trying
to grapple with a problem.
- Right, well I think
you probably have to,
yeah in order to concentrate
in the I'm talking
about I guess, you know,
if it's in the doctor surgery
or on the bus or whatever,
it might be you have to be
able to put other things
that are on your mind aside.
You know not to be distracted,
you certainly have to have that capacity.
I think that when you
talk about frustration,
it's true that philosophical problems,
any problems really if
you think through them,
are often very, very
frustrating you know ,
when you stuck with the problem,
you can't see your way out,
you've tried this, you've tried that,
you've tried the other,
you've read the background literature,
you find yourself just staring
at a blank page of paper,
you know when you're trying to
set down your ideas about it.
I found that actually, I do
find that very frustrating
and if I think I've hit a blank
wall it really bothers me.
I guess everybody experiences this,
that you've just got to live with it.
- In your work, especially
the book on freedom,
which we'll talk about in a minute,
there also seems in
your work to be a sense
of the history of the problem
and how it has evolved over
time in the work of philosophers
that have preceded you.
Talk a little about that
because the history of
philosophical thought seems
to be very important.
- Mm, well if I can
just do that by talking
about my own history in a way.
After University College Dublin,
at least after three or four years there,
I was lucky enough to
get a research fellowship
at a college in Cambridge,
Trinity Hall in Cambridge, England.
And there I came to be
very close to people
who work in the history of
ideas such as Quentin Skinner
and Richard Tuck.
Through them, I must say,
I became intrigued with
the history of this subject
and they concentrate,
it was often called the
Cambridge Contextual School,
on the context of historical ideas.
I became quite fascinated with that.
But on the other hand I sort
of felt this wasn't for me
that I really wasn't cut out
to be a historian of that kind
that I thought that I'd find
it impossible to get interested
in reading not just the greats
but the less great people
that the greats had read
and even less great
people that they had read
to know the full context.
So my response actually
was to go more theoretical
and in my philosophical thinking
and it really was only
10 or 15 years later
that I think I rediscovered the enthusiasm
for connecting with the history.
But that had laid the foundation
and I think I did so because of realizing
that with new technologies,
you could now access the historical texts.
For example you could take
a word and do a search
through the digital library
of some one like Hobbs
or any thinker and and immediately be able
to get these sources and
see how you describe,
so you in other words, you
are now getting for cheap,
skills that 20 years previously
would have required months
and years of work.
I think when that happened
my historical interest
sort of came back to
life and began to connect
with the philosophical thought.
- Before we talk about freedom,
I have one other question for you
and that is your sense
of theory and practice.
You've said in an interview
that you thought it was a two-way street.
I know that you were
part of an experiment,
which we'll talk about later,
on freedom but talk a
little about that interface
what in your background
made you sensitive to that.
Was it the student movement
that you were discussing earlier?
- Honestly I don't know really.
I think what is true that I've always felt
in particular with political philosophy
and to good extent in
other areas perhaps too
but in political philosophy
that if you are really trying
to think through both the
nature of our institutions,
how we should think about them
and the values that are
inherent in them sometimes,
they've ways in which
they fail those values,
the ways in which they might be improved,
that there's something, I
don't know, irresponsible,
I mean that's too harsh a word.
That there's something that
I don't find to my taste
in sort of then going away
and thinking about so to speak utopia
thinking about an abstract ideal world
rather than thinking
about where we can get to
from where we are in
our actual institutions.
Now of course in order to do that,
I think it's very, very
useful to have a sense
of how those institutions work and before,
I know you want to talk about Spain,
and my involvement there
which I'll happily do
but long before that I
had actually been asked
to do a review of the
Australian Capital Territory.
I worked full-time at the
Australian National University
at the time it was 1997
and there was a review of
self-government in that area.
The Australian Capital Territory,
it's like D.C., Australia's D.C.,
self-government had brought
in 10 years previously in 1987
and I was asked to
review how it had worked.
It was out of the blue.
It's just due to the fact
that some politicians
had known me personally
and knew about my interests.
And I took six months or
something off academic work
and I chaired this very small committee
with two really quite
outstanding public servants,
amazingly knowledgeable public servants
and I spent that six months really apart
from the time spent writing and thinking
and so on and reading,
I spent a lot of it just
in around the corridors
of a very small political unit.
But the interesting
thing is political units,
they work very similarly
even at different scales.
I felt that was for me a revelation.
I felt I really now had a sense
of how government can work
in the different
branches, the interactions
and the constraints and the
ideals that are important
to keep in place and the ways
in which they're likely always
to go off track with the
system becoming distorted
or even corrupted in various ways.
So that I think made a real
connection with practice
and no doubt my student days may
or at least my days of young faculty
in University College Dublin may have been
because I was involved in
wider politics in Ireland.
So that may also have
contributed to that interest.
- Interestingly what was the platform
on which you did this work?
By that I mean,
you clearly weren't examining
these government units
for their economic efficiency.
I mean you didn't come
there as an economist.
Did you come there as
somebody with a set of values
who had thought about values
and were looking at these units
from that perspective?
- Actually I came with a fairly open mind
because the remit I was
given was a very open remit
to after all the this
territory had been run
by the federal government
by a branch of the federal government
over you know the previous 60, 70 years
and this was really quite novel
that you had an electoral system,
you had a parliament,
you had an executive.
So what I found myself doing was looking
at the structure of Parliament
and of the executive,
how they're related to one
another, how the electoral,
the members of the legislature are related
to their constituencies,
how the constituencies were drawn.
One thing that really came
to my mind strongly was the relationship
between this system and
the Westminster system,
on the one hand,
which is the dominant paradigm
in Australia of course
and the Washington system on the other.
Because it turned out that in this area,
in Canberra basically, the
Australian Capital Territory,
it turns out that the the
government is really very rarely
at least then was rarely
controlled by a single party.
So in order to get government
in order for those elected
to the legislature to elect in turn
a functioning, reliable, stable executive,
they had to take people
from different parties
and independents and so on
and now that looks much
more Washington like
than it does you know the
single party type government
that you get in typically in Westminster.
I found that quite fascinating
and I found the talking to
people about the tensions
that they experienced in office
between satisfying their constituents
and satisfying the press gallery
and satisfying their colleagues
in caucus in the party
and in government.
I found that extraordinarily interesting.
I mean it was, it gave me an insight into,
at least I think it gave me an insight,
into how government works even though
at a very small scale
that I found really drove me,
stimulating you know.
- So your book is called
Just Freedom: A Moral
Compass for a Complex World.
I'll show that.
And so let's talk about that book
and what led you to undertake it
first of all and how long
did it take you to write it?
- Well if I could say the book,
the book rep is an expression
of a way of thinking
about politics which people
sometimes call Civic Republican
that sometimes nowadays Neo-republican
and I had really chanced
upon this tradition
and connected with it in
articulating my own ideas back
in the 1990s so I'd
published a book called,
Republicanism in 1997.
Probably not the best title
given an American audience
because it suggests that
it was a republicanism
in the GOP sense
where it's not really
a Civic Republicanism,
much more traditional
sort of way of thinking
and come to that in a moment.
And over the years between 1997
and when this was published in 2014
I'd obviously been involved
in various enterprises related
to this Republican tradition of thinking
and I know you want to bring me back
to one such enterprise in particular.
This book basically was intended as a book
that would make the approach accessible
to a wider audience than just scholars
or even university students.
So how I came to it.
That was back in the 90s that I,
so to speak came to the idea,
this way of thinking about freedom.
Two roads really to the
idea in my own case.
One I was thinking quite
abstractly or theoretically
about how we should conceive
of freedom politically.
If we grant that it's impossible
that we should ever
live in a solitary world
that we are essentially a social species
we live, clearly there's no
possibility for anyone of us
of living independently of others.
Now the tradition in some ways
of thinking about freedom
suggested you'd be perfectly free
if you lived in a solitary universe,
you know, you lived in the
state of nature all alone,
no one to get in your way,
you were perfectly free.
I think that's, when I say the tradition,
that's a way of thinking about freedom
that's certainly in the literature
and has long been there.
I was thinking about, well look,
suppose the solitary condition
isn't even a possibility
and you want to think about
what does freedom mean
if it's got to be something
that you can enjoy
in the presence of other people,
including other people who are bound
to get in your way in various ways.
And I'd begun to think that well,
perhaps we should think
of it as a sort of status
that we have vis-a-vis others
that we're free when we're given a space
where we can act according
to our own wishes
and where other people are not entitled
to interfere in that space
and it's not just
that they don't actually
interfere in that space
but they're blocked from
interfering in that space.
So it's not just, for example,
that I can act as I wish,
say, for example, in
reading whatever I wish
because you, who could stop me,
really rather likes the idea
of my reading whatever I wish
but should you turn against
me you would stop me.
I wouldn't enjoy freedom
in that status sense
if I depended on your permission
for being able to read what I wished.
I need to have that,
so to speak, protected
and secured against the
good will of others.
So I was thinking in that broad way
and then somebody said to me,
actually somebody who
did his PhD in Berkeley,
in history of ideas,
said to me that I should
perhaps look at some work
of Quentin Skinner's my
friend from Cambridge days.
Which I did and he led me
to read the long tradition
of so often called Republican thought
from Rome, through the Middle
Ages, through the Renaissance,
through the Dutch Republic,
the English Republic in the 17th century
and of course the American
and French republics
in the 18th century in particular.
And I found in these texts a
way of thinking about freedom.
I felt that it was exactly the one
that I was nudging or finding
my way loosely towards.
So on that way of thinking about freedom
in order to be free in
relation to other people it has
to be the case not just that
they don't get in your way
but that they're stopped.
They're not able to get in your way.
So in an image that I use in Just Freedom,
this particular book
to illustrate the idea,
I ask people to think
about the relationship
between Torvald and Nora,
the two protagonists of A Doll's
House Ibsen's famous play,
where Torvald, the husband,
a young banker has of course
all the legal and social and
cultural rights and powers
vis-a-vis Nora his young wife.
But he totally dotes on her,
worships the ground she walks on
and gives her as you
might say carte blanche
so she can act exactly as she wishes.
So the question I ask
is should we regard Nora
as enjoying freedom in
relation to Torvald.
Well now the very striking thing is that
in terms of the Roman and the Neo-Roman,
the long Republican way
of thinking about freedom,
the way of thinking about
freedom that the founders
in America certainly celebrated,
you could not say that
Nora enjoyed freedom.
Because while Nora did whatever she wished
within a certain range she
always did it implicitly
by permission of Torvald.
She depended on his goodwill.
So even though he didn't interfere,
even though she had carte blanche,
she had freedom as non-interference.
She still had a Dominus in the Roman term,
a lord or a master in her life.
So she enjoyed non-interference
but she did not enjoy non-domination.
Torvald was a master although
a sweet master, a kind master,
you know in the old
term but still a master.
And that's really the
core idea in this Civic
or older Republican way
of thinking about freedom
that you've got to not be
subject to the mastery of others.
- As you talk about this in your book,
it's very clear that this
is a structural theory
and often when you're
looking at structures,
the insight is not visible to the person
who's not really thinking
through the issue.
So Nora does appear to be free
but it's only by analyzing the structure
of the situation and you
do that throughout the work
that the true power relationship
is revealed is that fair?
- That is absolutely fair.
Because as you say freedom on this way
of conceiving of things
is a function not just
of the actions of other
people but of the powers
at the disposal of other people.
So if you exist as someone
who is relatively powerless
in relation to others,
where others have a power of interfering
even if they don't actually interfere.
The very fact of their having those powers
and you're not having any
sort of countervailing power
any anti-power as you might call it.
Means that you always live
really at their mercy,
you're exposed to their interference,
should they wish to interfere.
Of course you're going to know
this in general in most cases
and so that's also going
to put in place a motive
to defer, to keep the
powerful free to bend the knee
in the old terms you know,
to tug the forelock if you have one
or tip the cap, to kowtow.
These are all words in this tradition,
to fawn and to toady.
This is what you're going
to be motivated to do
in relation to others if you exist
as you say, within that
structural sort of scenario
where the others have got the
power and you don't have it.
- You make an important
distinction in American culture.
It sounds like you're
close to libertarianism
but you're making the point,
no that's not the case
because your insight is
in a way more powerful
about where freedom lies.
So what is it about libertarianism
that you disagree with?
- Well at the basic level
in the conception of freedom itself
the purely abstract level.
So on the libertarian
understanding of freedom
you're a free so long as you're not in,
you're free in a given choice.
Take a particular choice
like what to read,
where to travel, what job to take up.
You're free in so far as no one
actually interferes with you
on the libertarian conception.
On the older Republican
conception in order to be free
it has to be the case
that you are protected
against those sorts of,
secure against those
sorts of interferences.
I mentioned earlier that I
believe there's a real rupture
in the history of freedom
and it occurs ironically about the time
of the American Revolution.
The heroes of the American Revolution
and they're, for example,
supporters in England
such as Joseph Priestley the chemist
or Richard Price the mathematician
who are voluble supporters
of the Americans.
They all use the notion of
freedom I've been talking about.
So for example, Price says at one point
and he says that someone who's subject
to a master in a matter are
kindly a master is not free,
insofar as he still depends of
the good will of that master
and he says the same
is true of a community
and he suggests that that's what's true
about the American colonists.
The white American colonists of course
in relation to Westminster.
Again Joseph Priestley says what is it
that the Americans complain of
and he says it's not that the British
or the Westminster
Parliament are taking their,
are taking very much from them in tax.
They're only taking one penny he suggests
but it's that Westminster
Parliament claims the power
to take their last penny.
So what they're doing is they're
imagining the relationship
between London and the
American colonies of the time
as the relationship between
a master and a servant
and they're saying we're not free
because London is claiming
the position of a master.
Remember in 1766 when
London, the Parliament,
had lifted the the Stamp Act,
had withdrawn that particular tax,
had been very nice about it so to speak,
had been a really kindly master.
They added the Declaratory Act
that said of course we
insist that we have the power
and the right should we wish
to impose this sort of text,
this sort of tax.
So what they're claiming is precisely
that they have the powers
and the Americans immediately
react by saying we're not free
if these people claim their powers
and they're using the very idea of freedom
that had been popular in England
in the European tradition.
It goes right back to the Romans,
the idea that you're not free
if you're subject to
somebody else's good will.
They as a community are not free
'cause they're subject to the
good will now of Westminster
which has claimed that it has this power,
should you wish to
impose any tax or any law
that it wants to impose on the Americans.
So what happens in
England at this point is
that the defenders of
the English cause begin
to introduce a new way of thinking
about freedom and it becomes very visible
in particular in a
pamphlet published in 1776
by someone called John Lind.
And it's called Three
Letters to Dr. Price.
Dr. Price is Richard Price,
the one who had supported the Americans,
running the gentle master theme.
And in that document Lind,
it's a pamphlet really,
in support of the British government
in that document he says what is freedom
and he amazingly breaks
with a long tradition
and he says well to be free is just
to be not constrained or restrained.
So if you're not restrained
or restrained you're free
and if you are you're not free.
And then he says well that means
that the law always makes you unfree
to the extent to which are
subject to law your unfree.
That was very different
from the older view
which said law was the
protection against others
that actually made you free.
So even John Locke was
part of that tradition.
To be free was to enjoy
the protection of the law.
So you got your area where
you could act according
to your own will regardless
of what you wanted to do
and regardless of what
others wanted you to do.
Now what he's saying is law is
actually the enemy of freedom
and he then goes on to say,
well what's the complaint of the Americans
'cause we in England live
under a law that restrains us
and you in America live under
a law that restrains you
but what's the difference between us.
And why do you say you're not free
and we are free in England?
It's a very clever argument.
He has a footnote in that book
in which he says this way
of thinking about freedom
I derive from a very good friend.
A worthy and ingenious friend,
he describes him but doesn't name him.
Turns out the friend
had actually complained
to Lind about the fact
that he was using this way
of thinking about freedom
which he'd, the friend,
claimed to have invented.
He said it came to me
as a kind of invention
some six months hence.
That friend was Jeremy Bentham.
Really extraordinary sort of coincidence
because Bentham becomes, of course,
becomes the great theorist of
law in the English tradition
and is amazingly influential.
The great utilitarian
of course and a reformer
but he introduces this new
way of thinking about freedom
whereby it just requires
that you not interfered with.
It doesn't matter about
the power or the structure
as you were saying and that
then becomes the centerpiece
of the new classical
liberal views that appear
in the early 19th century the early 1800s.
- These examples of the
American Revolution point
to the fact that if you're gonna come up
with a powerful definition
of freedom you have
to articulate it with regard
to several domains which you do.
So it's freedom is that state
where you're free of domination,
where there's no domination
but it has to apply with
your relationship to others,
with other people situated as you are,
it has to apply in the relationship
of people to the government
and also the relationship between states.
So the examples you just
showed from the American
that was the germination of this idea
that it couldn't just be in one domain.
- Yes, I think of political
philosophy, political theory
as having really three domains of concern
and this notion of freedom
we're talking about,
has implications in each of those domains.
So just the three you mentioned,
let's think about the
first as the social domain.
The domain in which people relate
to their fellow citizens, I
suppose, within a given country.
Think of that as the social domain.
The second domain is you might think of it
as the political domain
which is not the relationship
between citizens and one another
but the relationship between
the citizenry as a whole
and their government.
And then of course the third
domain is the relationship
between different
societies mediated usually
in the relationships
between the governments
of the different societies.
Now I think that the
Civic Republican ideal
of freedom as non-domination
was traditionally used
in all of these domains actually
and that there is much to be said
for rethinking our ways of doing politics
and our policies and so on
by looking at the
ramifications or implications
of this ideal in those three domains.
You might think of the first
as a domain of social justice,
you know establishing a relationship
between citizens in social life such that
each of them can enjoy freedom
in relation to other citizens.
The second domain of
citizenry to government,
you think of as the domain
of political justice
that you want the citizenry as a whole
each considered as equal of course
to enjoy a relationship
with their government
such that they are not
dominated by their government
and in that sense they
enjoy political justice.
And then in relationship
between different societies,
I think the ideal of freedom
as non-domination gives
us a very nice line
into thinking about
international relations
and about the ways in which
societies should relate
to one another in the international forum,
ideally enabling each society
or at least each society
that is itself self-governing
and democratic,
there isn't an oppressive government
not to be dominated by other societies
and not of course to be dominated
by other international bodies
like multinational corporations
or for that matter churches are
of course international agencies.
- You have a brief phrase
to sum up the realization
of freedom in each of those
domain for social justice.
It's the eyeball test.
- The eyeball test, yes.
- Explain that.
- So in order to make vivid
in this book, in Just Freedom,
the ramifications of the notion
of freedom in each of these areas,
I suggest a sort of a rough-and-ready test
for determining whether
people are enjoying freedom
in any of these three domains
and in the social domain.
But this is not my invention,
actually you find this
in the 17th century.
In the social domain a good test
of whether people really
enjoy freedom in relation
to one another under the
organization of the state
and the economy and the law and so on is
whether people are able to
look one another in the eye
without reason for fear or deference.
They can in the old language
stand on their own two feet
and stand equal on a par with others.
Now I think we all know, you know,
that's why I say it's
a rough-and-ready test
but it's an applicable test.
We know when we live in a situation
where you're really not able
to look others in the eye.
So for example I don't mean
to be too contentious here
but I believe that if you've
got a working situation
where one person employs many others
and where that person has
a right to fire at will
without any negotiation
with a tribunal body
or a union for that matter
without any legal hurdles to cross,
is just able to fire at will
in a world where there's high unemployment
and being fired is a very
serious sort of loss to anybody.
When that person, the employer,
has that sort of power
in relation to an employee
then I think that's a case
where the employee is
really not going to be able
to look the employer in
the eye without reason
for fear or deference.
In fact being aware of that situation,
the employee in such a case
is going to have every reason
in the world, every motive in the world,
in the old 17th century
language to fawn and toady,
you know to kowtow and tip the
cap or whatever it might be.
I think that that's not a good way
of organizing our employment,
our workplace relations, for example.
If it induces that failure
of the eyeball test
in the workplace.
But of course there are many places
in social life apart from the workplace.
There's the public place,
there's the family place,
of course the home and
in all of these areas
I think it's important that
there be protections in place,
many of them legal and
many of them cultural
such that everyone really
has got his or her own space
and is able to look
others equally in the eye.
- In the realm of government and freedom
from the domination of the government
the test is tough luck.
- The tough luck test.
- Yeah, explain that.
- Yes, I'm not sure that
this is quite as intuitive
as the eyeball test.
But myself, I actually
find it fairly persuasive.
So it goes like this.
If I live in a society
where there are, say,
we've all got a vote and so on,
we're all able to contest what happens,
we're all able to write to
our Member of Parliament,
we're all able to join some NGO to protest
on one or another front against
what government is doing,
to have some influence,
we're all able to join a
demonstration whatever it is.
If we live in a society
where, first of all,
we have those personal powers shared
with our fellow citizens
and again we live in a
society where what happens
in the higher echelon, so to
speak, the corridors of power,
the various bureau and so on
and the various courtrooms
for that matter and tribunals are subject
to what we think of as
an impartial sort of rule
where no one's interests, not
the interests of the wealthy,
not the interests of a
particular religion or whatever,
no one's special interests
have particular force,
everyone is more or less well represented,
interests in general are well represented.
Then you'll be in the
following situation that
when the government or the
legislature passes a law
and of course this is the
legislature you help elect
and it's responsive to you and
to fellow citizens equally.
When they pass a law and you
really believe with this system
that you are equally represented
with others in this system
and that those in your neck of the woods,
your corner of society are
not particularly suppressed
or whatever not particularly
second-rate citizens
then what you're going to believe
about a piece of legislation
even when it goes against you,
so perhaps the government
introduces a measure in taxation
that doesn't particularly
go down well with you
or those in your particular area
in the economy, for example,
you should be able to think of the fact
that this legislation goes
against your particular interests.
You should be able to think that,
well you know I believe in our system,
I think I'm equally represented
with others in that system
so I can think about this
as it's hard, it's tough,
but it's just tough luck.
It's not that somebody
has got it in for me.
It's not that there's
a power in government
that is representing other sectors
of society more strongly than mine.
So that really what's
happening to me is a result
of the fact that government
is in the control
of another section of the community,
no rather government is responsive
to all the sides of the community.
And so I'm able to think
about what government does
even when it acts in a way
that's not welcome to me
as that's just tough luck.
Now I think if we had a
society where you could think
about legislation that even
ran against your wishes
that it was just tough luck
that's a good sign that
you're living in a society
where the government, the source
of law and order and so on,
in this society is a government
that's responsive to you
equally with others so that
no one of you is dominated
by that government as by
an independent agency.
It's an agency that is responsive
to each of you equally with others,
you've got to live with others
that's part of the human condition
and so you're not dominated in so far
as that government has that
sort of responsiveness to all.
- And with regard to global justice.
What is the catchphrase there?
- The catchphrase there
is straight-talking.
Imagine the relationship
between the the Ukrainian government
and the Russian government as of now
where, for example, the
Russian government clearly
you've got troops on the border
or in the precincts of the border
and clearly you have a deep
influence over the the people
in eastern Ukraine and are able
to turn off the gas at any point.
The relationship between
those two governments is
clearly one of domination.
I mean the Ukrainian government is
in a situation where they really,
other forces absent would
have to kowtow and toady
and fawn and so on,
would really not be free
in relation to that other government.
Now of course it's very unstable
and an unhappy situation the
fact that the European Union
and that the United States is
to good extent backing the Ukrainians,
can give them a certain sort of boost
and maybe restore some degree of equality
in that relationship.
But it's obviously very,
it's still very problematic.
Now I think in relationships
general between states,
we have to think, first of all,
let's imagine we're talking about states
that are if not perfect democracies
and I actually believe very few states
are anything near perfect in terms
of the ideal of political justice, right?
In almost every country
government is often subject
to the special influence
of particular groups
who control government.
So people really don't
enjoy full political freedom
in relation to the government.
But imagine for a moment
that we have got states
where we're not complaining
about them domestically,
they're politically okay.
So what would it be to establish relations
between these states
such that no one society
would be dominated by others,
are dominated by multi-national agencies.
Now this is a really big challenge.
I mean your own area of interest
is international relations,
so you will be very sensitive to this
because of course states
differ enormously in power,
in military power, in economic power,
in cultural power, in diplomatic clout,
they differ in enormous respects.
So it's a real challenge there.
Now I think that it is very important
from the point of view of countries
that they're not dominated
because if they are by another country
that impacts in turn on the residents,
the citizens of that country.
They become sort of second-rate citizens
in the global order.
So I think we really should
work towards this sort of ideal.
It's another question
about how we can begin
to achieve anything like that ideal.
Now I think international
agencies like the United Nations
and the various bodies
of the United Nations,
they are really absolutely crucial
and one of the very sad things
that I see happening nowadays
is a sort of withdrawal
of trust from these international
organizations and bodies
on the grounds that they're
suffering a Democratic deficit
as it's often put.
I think that's way overstated.
These bodies after all are subject
to the control of the governments
who appoint the officials and so on
and those officials and international law,
international regulations,
international standards
which are, you know,
hammered out over tables
where countries are represented.
I think that that's the only hope
of establishing an international order
where when the leaders of
countries talk to one another,
they can talk straight
you know they don't have
to mealy-mouthed on the one hand
or speak with the tones
of a master on the other.
- It strikes me that your
definition of freedom
through its simplicity and it
application across domains,
helps save freedom
as a virtue, as a value
for progressive ideals
in the sense that you're not saying
that the state should do nothing
because you're also saying
I can't be equal with you
unless my position, their
programs or policies
if I'm in poverty that
elevate me to be your equal
if you're not in a similar situation.
So the virtue of what you're saying
and its distinction from
libertarianism on the one hand
and its emphasis on
structure on the other,
allows freedom to have a new
constituency shall we say
in terms of the divisions
that occur in our country.
- Absolutely I mean I think the tradition
and the ideas are of interest
on all sides of politics
but my own thinking about what's required
for giving substance and life
to this ideal of freedom,
a freedom that's non-domination
in these three different areas leads me
to support very progressive policies
and I think they are quite different
from the policies in general
that libertarians would support.
So I'll give you an example.
Take the workplace example.
I mean libertarians will always insist
on the right to fire at will.
It's one of the basics
or libertarian demands.
But you give the right to fire at will
to an employer and you
immediately create an asymmetry
between employer and employee.
Its standard libertarian line
to decry unions for example.
Well, I must say, I deeply
regret the loss of union power
because while corporations,
unions have never been angels,
I mean they've always had
their their own problems,
the same is true of corporations.
And what's happening with
the decline of unions is
that you don't have a countervailing power
against the power of corporations
in dealing with employees.
Which means in turn of
course that the employees,
more and more get into a
position where they are dominated
or take a situation of, for example,
I think it's very important
that welfare legislation be in place,
including national health
or some form of national
health, public health system
so that people aren't put in the position
of having to depend on
the grace and goodwill
of their betters and the wealthier.
Now libertarian doctrine will
always tell you philanthropy
that's what we want more
and more philanthropy.
Now I believe philanthropy
is a great thing
and well organized it can
be force for unalloyed good
but the idea that someone should depend
on the pro bono favor of doctors,
family they happen to know or whatever,
in order to get proper medical treatment.
I mean I know that doesn't happen
but just take that as a commonly
but that is really anathema
to the idea of freedom
that we're talking about
'cause it means that the
person who's ill has got
to depend on the grace and
favor of the local doctor
who's not going to charge
a fee or whatever it is.
You've got to have an
infrastructure of protection
in society in order to
ensure that people are going
to enjoy the capacity
that will enable them
to pass the eyeball test.
And I think one thing
that's worth saying here,
if I can add Harry, is that
in libertarian thought,
it's often suggested that
we have a natural order
which is an order of
ownership and the market
but that's not a natural order.
That's created by law.
Property only exists in virtue of a law.
If I were in a state of nature
and I hold on to this I
can possess it you know
and you can take it from me.
But it doesn't exist as property
unless we have a law that basically says
that the forces of the
community are going to rally
behind me if you try to take it from me.
They're going to support my claim.
Law creates property, law equally creates
and of course facilitates markets
and that's a great thing,
I mean I'm a great believer in markets.
This is by no means some sort
of neo-Marxist view or anything.
But just as law creates
property and ownership
and the market, it's perfectly
fine that law should be there
to enable and facilitate people
to enjoy the basic requirements of life
as in welfare legislation
to enjoy, for example,
assurance of legal representation
if they are brought before the courts
whether privately or by the
government in criminal charge,
to enjoy an assurance about their medical,
recourse to medical help in the
case of necessity and so on.
All of these are essential infrastructure
if you're going to have freedom
as non-domination enjoyed
in the social sphere
within a given society.
- You were part of an
extraordinary experiment,
shall we say, in which a
new Spanish Prime Minister
about a decade ago had read
your book, an earlier book,
on Civic Republicanism,
invited you to be part of a process
of the implementation of new policies
and if I can summarize briefly
because of the time you
address the Parliament
with laying out the
ideals of republicanism
and then after the government existed
and was implementing these policies,
you actually did a report
card for the government
on how the policies were being implemented
in the different provinces.
I guess the tire really
hit the road, (laughing)
very interfaced with practice.
What did you see in that whole process?
What did you learn that
informed your understanding
of Civic Republicanism at that time?
- Well the story, just
to fill in a little bit,
was that Mr. Zapatero
when he became leader
of the Socialist Party
in Spain was looking
for a philosophy.
He had this view that as a government,
as he hoped to become the
government, of course,
he would have a general
philosophy of government
what it was about, what law was about,
what policy making was about.
And he came upon my book.
He read widely apparently
and he decided that this
was where he wanted to go.
And I had known in the early 2000s,
I heard from friends in Spain
about my name being used
and the book being used and so on
and then in 2004 he was elected
and he at that stage invited
me to give a lecture in Madrid
in a very large forum actually
with a lot of politicians
and ministers and so on and government,
there by invitation,
to talk about this Republican philosophy
which he had espoused and
espoused the book so to speak.
As he said as his vade mecum, you know,
that he brought with him.
And I gave that lecture
and he was to respond to it
but in the course of the
lecture I turned to him
in a slightly jokey way
and I said, well look,
he'd been just three months in power
but one thing he had done which
I supported in the book was
to make the National Broadcaster
independent of government.
Up to that point the National Broadcaster,
apparently a minister who could say I want
to be on the six o'clock
news or I want to be there
when I'm opening the supermarket
you know I want a report
and the broadcaster did the favor.
He made the broadcaster into like a BBC,
independent of government
and I thought this was a terrific idea.
I think it's really important
that you have an independent broadcaster.
Maybe not necessarily of that kind
but certainly like your
public broadcasting and so on.
I turned him and I said
now you've done this
and I think this is wonderful but I said,
it's very easy be a philosopher like me
but you're going to you lead
one of the largest economies
in the world, the ninth
largest economy in the world.
And I said you're going
to find, for example,
the National Broadcaster is
going to be your worst critic
on some fronts and you're going
to find it really hard not
to pick up that phone and remind them
about how much they are in your debt
and try to sort of influence them
that will be a real temptation.
I don't have that temptation
you're going to have that.
And I explained that
as I thought it would be
very, very hard to live up
to the principles of this way of thinking,
this narrow Republican way of thinking
and in his response to me,
he basically gave up the
comments he was going
to make I think and he
invited me publicly,
he insisted he was absolutely
committed to running
with this program in these
policies, these ideas
and he invited me to do a
report on his government
which I would publicize six
months before the next election
which is due four years later.
And someone in the audience
immediately stood up
who was the head of a
foundation in Spain and said
that this foundation will
support Professor Pettit's work
and bring him back and
so on to give the report.
Actually it wasn't at all
the sort of thing I had
as an ambition to do or even
an inclination really to do.
I could see straightaway the hard work
that was going to be involved
in reading what was happening
and so on but I agreed to do it.
And sometimes people say that
I advised that government.
I didn't advise the government.
They very nicely asked if I would give,
I said there's be a conflict of interest,
of course if I'm doing a report.
But over that four years they
brought in various policies
and I talked on a number
of occasions with Zapatero.
I had one particularly
long interview with him
where he sought to persuade
me that these policies were
in fact motivated by the principles
of this near Republican way of thinking
and then I presented the report in,
about four months before
the election in 2007.
- Well on that note,
there's a limit with our time constraints
that we can cover
but let me recommend
your book to our audience
'cause it's beautifully written
and it's an opportunity to
explore this idea of freedom
that is kind of different
from what we normally hear
at least in the United States.
Thank you very much Professor Pettit
for coming here today.
- Thank you.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation With History.
(gentle music)